the ancient Celts worshipped trees they
believed to be the home of spirits of
gods and if you are having a run of good
luck you would knock on the tree to show
gratitude but if you said something
boastful you knock on the tree creating
the noise to cover up what you said so
the spirit inside wouldn't bring down an
ironic wrath many cultures believe that
a ladder against the wall forms a symbol
of life the triangle whose three sides
were thought to symbolize the holy
trinity walking under a ladder breaks
that symbol tempting fate and inviting
death oh and another reason to avoid
walking under ladders dangerous in
ancient Rome salt was considered a
valuable commodity and it was a symbol
of trust and friendship because it was
precious and long-lasting so spilling
said friendship salt is considered bad
luck another possible origin lies within
two Vinci's Last Supper here you can see
Judas has knocked over the salt with his
elbow and so now because of Judas
spilled salt is associated with lies and
treachery
way to ruin salt Judas the Romans
creators of both glass mirrors and this
superstition believed mirrors had the
power to steal part of your soul just by
looking at it and if the mirror was
broken your soul will be trapped inside
for a hamburger this superstition also
dates back to the Last Supper where 13
dinner guests the night Christ was
betrayed the number was soon considered
unlucky additionally in the 1800s some
gallows would have 13 steps leading up
to them and let's face it if you're
walking up to the gallows you're pretty
unlucky